see i was in sports as i mentioned and
there it's very different I played
football when you kick a goal you are in
the newspaper the next day immediate
there is a media there is not a second
between you having kicked the goal and
do being a hero that's not the way it is
in science there you have typically your
own doubts and then you have the
criticism from outside and sends away
until others have tried to repeat so but
I had the education from sports let's
take high jumping the odds experience of
failing or succeeding in high jumping
it's intense pain instantaneous but it's
also the experience of what it means to
have reached a certain level of
achievement